Muy buenas tardes como usted bien lo
decía esa Damián sea ya puesto la
camiseta ese mayo amarillo de líder de
esta edición 110 del Tour de Francia y
lo hizo tras imponerse en un Sprint en
un duelo en Sprint ante su hermano
gemelo Simona y jates por supuesto pues
una carrera que como esperábamos de
estos 182 kilómetros alrededor de Bilbao
Pues que fuera con muchísimas cosas
bastante explosivas esa era un poco la
trampa que debía evitarse el día de hoy
un día en el que vimos además un
accidente una calle unas caídas bastante
fuertes de dos líderes el líder de
Movistar Enric más quien terminó
retirándose de este Tour de Francia
primer retiro de esta carrera y también
de Richard carapaz en la campeón
ecuatoriano que también pues sufrió
bastante fuerte esa caída y demoró un
poco antes de volverse a subir en su
bicicleta Aunque lo hizo muy valiente él
y terminó pero eso sí 15 minutos o por
detrás de Adams en cuanto a los dos
grandes favoritos por supuesto
del que forma parte también Adams Pues
él cruzó en la línea tercero y logró
sacarle ya cuatro segundos de ventaja y
Garden en todo caso ese era un duelo que
estábamos esperando ver y que esperamos
ver a lo largo de todo este Tour de
Francia y ya vemos que está bastante
bien en marcha Natalia que sigue ahora
en los próximos días para el Tour Cuáles
son las expectativas
muchísimas expectativas porque este tour
está sobre todo hecho digamos a la
medida de los que son buenos en la
montaña menos para los que logran hacer
buenos Sprint hoy de hecho sufrieron
bastante ellos En todo caso pues este
tour continua aquí en el en el país
Vasco mañana etapa entre Victoria
gasteiza y San Sebastián el lunes
también partirá de aquí antes ya de
regresar a Francia será con una llegada
en bayona y por supuesto a partir del
miércoles tendremos ya dos etapas de
montaña las etapas en los pirineos así
que ya ahí será digamos los momentos ya
las grandes pruebas de fuerza para los
asientos setenta y cinco ya porque ya no
son 176 en vista de que más ya no está
en este tour y veremos Entonces qué
sucede pero ahí ya vamos a ir viendo
poco a poco Cómo se va digamos
decantando En todo caso
todo este pelotón Y por supuesto pues
pendientes de lo que suceda en los
pirineos antes de llegar a los alpes la
siguiente semana